uh
with a polo g you know polo's like
somebody who obviously is a very very uh
he's got his head on his shoulders um
good kid man like is there has it been
anything you've learned from him
personally like just being on the road
with him being close to him
outside of the live [ __ ] we're talking
about just like maybe how he does his
like handles certain [ __ ] or has he
given you any game because you know he's
he's on a crazy level right now as far
as success yeah
one thing i pulled up he like he don't
talk a lot though
you know i i used to be like that but i
used to think like damn i can't be no
rapper and be like that right well look
at brad up there you see what i'm saying
he done blew weight up and still like
that but still you know you still got a
politic or whatever he i'm pretty sure
he'd do that but other than that he'd
just be like to himself like
entire social life on some longer taishi
yeah
i think it used to be a problem when i
used to be like that
some people be like that and people take
it the wrong way when it's just really
just how they are yeah and i learned
that too i learned that too that you
can't always take be getting emotional
when someone's yeah on the same vibe as
you bro a new a [ __ ] ain't in front of
just
do it be this just because they quiet or
whatever they ain't talking on there
they don't mean they don't [ __ ] with you
that's probably how he is yeah i'm
saying
um obviously because of getting a
feeling it's like oh bro
he thinks he's too good or he's a weirdo
it's like man sometimes just people
ain't gonna they they got their own way
they move on [ __ ] with me see i'm saying
people
just jump jump jump to conclusions that
aren't necessary crazy [ __ ]